[Music]
the ominous fade out
are we good awesome
hi everyone one uh welcome to the table
um i'm so glad to see um all of you guys
here who are here with us in person and
i want to say thank you and welcome for
those of you who are joining us at home
and online
um we're just glad that you're just a
part of our family
i just have one quick announcement
that's basically it
is that we have a book club that's
starting up um may 15th um
the name of the book is uh called cass
um it's my s
um i'm gonna read this because i'm gonna
get the name author wrong isabelle wilk
wilkerson
um i've actually heard about this book a
few dozen times
um it sounds like a really good book
from the things that i've heard about it
i'm personally an audiobook kind of a
person so you give me a handbook to read
i'm
i'm not gonna probably read it but i
will listen to the audiobook so
this might be something you might be
interested in but if there's nothing you
might want to kind of kind of sign up
sarah's going is the one who is leading
this
she's sending out links she's sending
out stuff on facebook if you want to
sign up there
let her know that you're interested in
doing this this is going to be a virtual
event
so you don't have to worry about you
know all the different things that we
have to worry about when we're doing
social distancing kinds of things
um but just kind of keep that in mind um
and then i'm just going to
end us start us with a prayer lord
thank you so much for just bringing us
here today
thank you for just this opportunity
to get together to come
and to worship you to connect with you
and just to be in your presence i pray
you open our hearts and our minds
um and just in service what you have for
us to hear
in christ and i pray amen
thanks dawn all right you guys
well let's go ahead and stand together
[Music]
if this is um one of your first times
i'm mindy this is noelle and josh
and tyler and um
i'm gonna take this off while i sing
this is an opportunity for us to just be
together and
sing songs as friends about a god and to
a god that we believe
is on our side who is for us who loves
you who accepts you
so we just invite you into that space
with us just feel at home
there um seeing if you would like to or
if you want to just focus on the words
clap this first song does have a little
section in it
where i would love for you guys to join
in you might have been here a couple
weeks ago when we did it for the first
time
but it doesn't take a lot it's just a
quick little
section but it's so good for us to be
like in our bodies sometimes you know
what i mean we can be
like spend the whole day like in our
heads or just talking
and we don't often i feel like
like you go to other cultures and it's
crazy
watching their church services like
especially i mean i've only actually
been to
africa the only other continent i've
been to but you guys if you go to their
church services like
it's so physical you're like finishing
the service and it's like i feel like i
just got the best of work workout in my
life
and then here we are like this the
entire you know what i mean
so it's good for us to kind of engage
those literal muscles
and use our bodies to engage like this
is how god created us
we're people and we have skin and we
have muscles so
we can use them in our worship too all
right
let's get going
we dream of you
city streets breathing
again
[Applause]
[Music]
we dream of you
at kitchen
[Music]
[Applause]
we are children
of grace
[Music]
[Applause]
our
[Music]
to be together again
in
[Applause]
all right you guys let's take this out
together
[Music]
let the people sing the songs of joy
let their eyes crown
let the river run
let the people sing the songs
let the earth rejoice
[Applause]
[Music]
let the
[Applause]
[Music]
all right just our voices ready let the
earth
let the people sing the songs of joy let
the rocks
let the rocks cry out let the rivers
let the people sing their songs
[Music]
uh this is an older song that i grew up
playing
um so as when i was practicing this week
it didn't really hit me but then tonight
when
we were playing it mindy was like you
should say something because the vibe of
the first song and then the vibe of this
song is completely different it's a lot
slower
so i'm trying to fill that gap too but
it also struck me that
this song also meant a lot to me growing
up um
and i think it's just the melody of the
song it's just really pretty
and it just makes you think of uh
your spiritual father
[Music]
i don't know just sit back you don't
have to stand if you want to stand you
can
but uh sing out and
just see what the song does for you
you are so good to me
you heal my broken heart
you are my father in heaven
[Music]
you are so good to me
you heal my broken heart
you are my father
in heaven
but you are beautiful my sweet sweet
song
you are beautiful my sweet
sweet song
you are beautiful my sweet and sweet
[Music]
song again
you right upon the clouds
you lead me to the truth
you are the spirit
inside me
you're right upon the clouds
you lead me to the truth
you are the spirit
inside me
but you are beautiful my sweet sweet
song
to my sweet sweet song
you are beautiful my sweet sweet song
i will sing again
you are my strong
melody you
are my dancing
[Music]
and i want to sing
forever
you poured out all your blood
you died upon the cross
you are my jesus who
loves me
you poured out all your blood
you died upon the cross
you are my
loves me
you are beautiful my sweet sweet song
[Music]
if you are beautiful my sweet
again
i'll see you again hey
we sing to you
[Applause]
[Music]
again
we're going to take some time to do a
tradition that's called prayers of the
people
you might have been here last week when
we did this together
but um basically what it is is a time
for us
to go through i'm gonna read a short
prayer to begin us
with and then there will be some space
for you guys to join in
and speak out something that's on your
heart
it can be a person's name that might be
on your heart somebody that you know is
going through something
or just someone that you've been
thinking of
that maybe is not close to you or
it could be so many things but you don't
need to share what's going on with them
you just need to say their name
or maybe it's something even bigger it
could be situational or something that
our country is experiencing or
communities that
are on your heart so we're just going to
open that up together and go ahead and
just say that out as a community
it's so such a beautiful time for us to
be able to share and participate
together
in this prayer because god cares
about what's going on in our lives and
he cares about you and he cares about
the people
around us so we just want to make some
space for that and then at the end of it
i will
um close us out at the very end with
another short
prayer and then we'll go ahead and go in
to raise a hallelujah
all right
for this city of saxi texas and for
every city and community
and all of those who live in them we
pray to you
for the good earth that you have given
us
and the wisdom and the will to conserve
it
we pray to you
for those who travel on land or sea
or air we pray to you
for the old and the sick for the widow
and the orphan for the injured
the suffering we pray to you
[Music]
for the poor and the oppressed
the unemployed and the destitute for the
prisoners
and the captives and for all who we
remember
and we care for we pray to you
and lord we know that you love us and
that you hear us
and so now we lift up these names
to you
[Music]
cj
for those whose names we have spoken
aloud and for those that we have kept in
our hearts
we pray to you for life and light
[Music]
for healing and hope
peace and the deep sense of your
presence god amen hallelujah
in the presence of my enemies
louder than the unbelief
[Music]
is
comes to fight for me
louder and louder
up from the ashes
death is defeated the king is alive
i raise a hallelujah
with everything inside of me
i'll raise a hallelujah
[Applause]
and i will watch the darkness
[Music]
[Applause]
i
[Music]
me
in the middle of the storm
[Music]
louder and louder you're gonna hear my
praises throw up from the ashes
[Music]
ashes
is defeated the king is alive
sing a little louder
a little louder sing a little louder
sing a little louder in the presence of
my enemies
[Music]
[Applause]
is my enemies
[Music]
[Applause]
gonna sing in the middle of the storm
louder and louder
[Music]
the storm louder and louder
you're gonna hear my praises more
love from the ashes
hope will arise is defeated
the king is alive
[Music]
miss jesus thank you for time together
to lift our voices
[Music]
to speak out words of who you are to us
to say the things that we believe to be
[Music]
true
that you're with us even when we're
doubting even in our
disbelief you are present
and you are close
you are with us and present in our pain
and you are a beautiful god
[Music]
a god of love a god of mercy
and grace and second chances
you redeem us
[Music]
you change us
and you love us so well
may we come to know you more
tonight as we're together and as we
leave this place god
would you continue to overwhelm us with
your goodness
would you continue to show up in the
small insignificant moments of our days
would we find you there reminding us
that you are good
would we find you in the ways that we
serve and love the people around us
would you meet us there would you give
us the energy in the capacity
and the grace to love our world
our families our co-workers
our kids
we love you and we need you we want more
of you in our lives
amen
all right you guys thanks for worshiping
with us why don't you guys just turn and
wave to the people around you
say a quick hello and then brett will
get us started with the message
hello hello good evening everyone
grace and peace y'all doing well
good good good good um well
my name is brett and i'm the founding
pastor here at the table
and i want to just extend that warm
welcome to all of you
um but especially if you're new or those
joining us
online we love you lots you are not
forgotten
not even a bit um i love our extended
table family
and uh and it's it's awesome to see a
few faces here i haven't seen in a while
um that makes me really excited so um
well let's see we are in this is part
three
of our series uh titled new normal
and kind of our um our guiding insight
has been uh that as human beings we
really don't like change
um i mean a few there's it's sort of a
strange personality that some people
some of you do anyone like
really love change and it may be a few
maybe
not not many maybe josh brock does the
guy who's playing guitar he does
um no that's not like super normal um
lots of yeah most of us are kind of i
mean i'm like i am not a change person
i'm
love my routine love my plan i just let
me just stick to the plan
just all day every day
and so kind of the purpose of the series
is really that this is largely who we
are
and so because of that uh this pandemic
really shot our wheels off
it was oh oh gosh oh every oh
everything's changing and
um and so but the thing is even though
it was really difficult there's kind of
a um
kind of a blessing or something
beautiful hiding within it because what
it did
was it opened up the possibility for us
to make
changes and to gain new insights into
ourselves others god
that we would have never gleaned
otherwise and because of that there's
this like
opportunity to establish a new normal
right to incorporate
some of what we learned into um
this this new normal that we're all kind
of trying to establish in the coming
months so
that's kind of the idea of this series
we're just trying to take you know some
advantage
uh take advantage of this of this season
that we're in so with that in mind uh
and
uh i wanna um start we'll be in matthew
um chapter eight verses 23-25 the title
of the message though is
same boat same boat
and this is a pretty famous jesus story
familiar to
um to some of you i'm sure it says then
jesus
got into the boat and his disciples
followed him suddenly a furious storm
came up on the lake so that the waves
swept over the boat
but jesus was sleeping
the disciples went and woke him saying
lord save us i imagine this wasn't like
lord save us i mean i noticed the
exclamation marks there
lord save us we're going to drown
uh i still i still remember um
the very i mean i remember exactly where
i was sitting
the moment i realized
that this pandemic we were um at that
time about to go through
um like that it really kind of hit home
for me um and i realized like oh gosh oh
this is a thing oh this is gonna be a
thing
like everywhere um and i just finished
i was sitting with my my uh two good
friends josh reynolds and jesse watts
and we had just finished watching this
is mid-march last year and we just
finished watching the joker
um which is a dark movie
it's if you've seen it's real dark i
don't know if i can recommend it
um but it is really good but dark
um not encouraging uh so i just finished
it and i'm kind of sitting there in a
little bit of a dark mood
but kind of you know i'm really thinking
and then my friend jesse he turns to me
and he says so um
so kasia kasha by the way is his wife
cash has been doing a little
some research on this coronavirus
and she says it's going to spread all
over the world
and infect millions upon millions of
people and
who knows how many people will die and i
remember
turning to him and saying what
no that's what i said he will never let
me live this down by the way he brings
us up consistently when we're hanging
out remember that time
you didn't think the coronavirus is
going to be a thing like yeah okay bud
you can stop
uh and that's what he says and uh i was
like
what no i was really no
sure my phrase was surely not that's
what i said
that's the thing he always brings up
surely not brett surely not
and so he he leaves
and i'm sitting there still in the same
chair and i get on my phone and i mean
i'm an ign5 any gram five for anyone who
who
follows instagram stuff so i'm like
researcher
you know i'm like okay so i just our
article article article article article
and within about 10 minutes i was like
oh gosh oh
dear lord and then i but i sit there for
an hour
um maybe a little bit longer i'm just
article article and and
as i'm going through i now i had i knew
kind of where it spread it would go
china europe
i knew it was in washington this time in
new york that still seen far away
you know it's like way up there pacific
northwest
northeast just like okay but in my
research
i realized not only was it in texas a
few
but in texas it was also in dallas
county
there are three confirmed cases in
mid-march in dallas county and when i
read that i was like
oh my gosh like because i just realized
if it's gone from china
to texas that was real quick that seemed
real quick
and and two things hit me um first i
knew that our world was about to change
uh and with our church and then
second i realized just
just how um powerfully connected
and intertwined we all are
i don't just mean here like us this
community i mean like the entire world
just and i knew this like intellectually
you know i mean like i knew all about
like
globalization the world has shrunk
in the sense of you know where it used
to take months to travel around the
world and now it's like
24 hours you can be almost anywhere and
you know so i like i understood
international travel and the internet of
course has kind of brought us all close
in that sense where we're just
very aware of different cultures
different perspectives different ways of
viewing the world i mean if you imagine
growing up you know even just a hundred
years ago
like you pretty much knew the people in
your little town
and that's like and so whatever they
believed you believed
that's it like their politics your
politics their religion your religion i
mean it's just that was your world
you know and so of course that has so
changed and like and i know that
you know i'm like yeah of course we're
all i mean i would have probably could
have preached a sermon like yeah we're
all connected you know that's so true
but i but i just it was all up here
you know which is a real problem for me
i'm like
too many things can be up here actually
as mindy was talking about during
worship not really
known like in the in my body in my in my
guts we kind of use that metaphor you
know i'm just like in the core of who i
am there's a difference between knowing
something here
and knowing something like boom in the
center right and that's what happened
all of a sudden it hit me
in my core like experientially
oh my gosh we are
profoundly connected
to one another and in um
i will not spend my whole message
talking about the the pandemic
um and and really what i'm what i want
to do is kind of use this as a picture
as a metaphor in a way because
because of course we are it's true
geographically um because of you know
travel and things we are more connected
than we used to be
and you know physically spatially we're
more connected we can be in different
places in the world
um but really what i'm what i'm talking
about is um
psychologically um emotionally if you
were here two weeks ago i just
just barely touched on this idea of how
we're we're extremely
tuned into one another at levels we
don't even
consciously understand but you have
already picked up
the moods and the attitudes and the
vibes of
more people in this room than you
realize um like we're just we're deeply
connected so i'm talking psychologically
emotionally
and i believe even spiritually though i
can't necessarily
explain that i it's sort of a
more intuitive um thing i think god
because we're connected to god in in the
spirit of god is present
everywhere i think we're more connected
to others
than we realize and like i said i could
have
i could have preached that like two
years ago but it
but it's different it's it's different
now it's really hit me at a new
level um there's a quote i came across
um martin luther king jr
uh he said in a real sense all
of life is interrelated all
men he of course here means humanity
he's just writing a while ago
um all all people were caught in an
inescapable
network of mutuality tied in a single
garment
of destiny you probably could have just
tell
this was mlk even if i hadn't told you
that just from those metaphors
so he's a magnificent writer tied in a
single garment of destiny
whatever affects one directly
affects all indirectly can you see how
that happens
right because of this connection
whatever happens to you whether it's
caleb
graham mike right like whatever whatever
kind of happens to you
directly it's not that everyone
experiences it exactly
like you did or to the exact same depths
but it it what's the idea it
ripples out from you it ripples out
because you're a connected
you're connected person now remember um
king of course he's writing the 1960s
and so his context he's he's really
speaking
primarily at that time to white folks to
a group of people who
wanted to um
act as though they were separate
right i'm i'm over here you're over
there and this is literally in terms of
segregation
like this was the world it was legally
instantiated right so i'm over here
you're over there
my group's over here your groups over
there and it was
and this was sort of the the myth that
was being lived under
um at that time and and i think this is
what king's speaking to and he's saying
no
he's like nope that is
a myth you're this is a story you want
to tell yourself
about how you know how i live it's just
these are these are my choices these are
my beliefs this
is who i am and it doesn't impact anyone
else
you know how we live it doesn't impact
anyone else and he's like no no
no no this is profoundly
impacting um everyone collectively
um we we are all
in the same boat
um this is i think even true when
there's not a geographical
like location connection or even in a
situation where you're estranged from
someone have you ever known
maybe you've experienced this in your
own life like i've um
i've known folks who are kind of a
strange maybe it's a parent
it could be a sibling maybe maybe best
friend they grew up someone that was
like very
formative for them and yet now something
happened
a rift a conflict something and now they
haven't spoken to each other
in 10 15 20 25 years i mean it can be a
while
and yet they are still so
powerfully defined by precisely that
relationship
is that not un that's astounding right
because we think well
now we're disconnected you know there
over here i'm over here so
and it's like oh my gosh we can't get
away from it
right and it's through how does it
happen i don't know i mean it's it's
through memories
it's through feelings uh words we
remember
it just and and i've seen i have a few
people in mind who i know now they've
had children
and you can see how they've been so
powerfully impacted by that relationship
often not in good ways
that now that ripple effect is going
where
it's like literally going into the next
generation
right you can't trust people right these
kind of messages these themes
it's like it's amazing how even in a
strange relationship
uh where we think we're separate it's
like no we're still
we're all in the same boat
of course um so far all of my
uh kind of examples have been quite
gloomy we got covid
racism estrangement um there's good news
like this can also be positive
so i should probably name that um you
know
uh i'm thinking of okay for example
think of maybe it's a parent a mentor a
teacher a coach
someone from back in some formative
years for you
who had a positive impact on your life
and just
i mean how can you even begin to
calculate
what that has meant to you
and and to future generations like
that's
it's remarkable isn't it i had um an
experience i think i told this story
maybe online during the pandemic
um but it's it's a good one so i'll tell
it again um
i i was in i was 16 years old
and i was attending i was a worship
leading worship at a little country
church
lucas christian church at lucas texas
and uh and i remember i led worship and
then i kind of came down these little
steps
and there was a woman who i'd never seen
before and she was kind of across the
way and she was kind of like
you know making eye contact with me like
kind of looking at me like she wanted to
talk or something you know
and so she kind of starts you know
walking towards me
and she walks up to me and she says um
i have a word from god for you that's
what she said
and i was like oh okay this is very
intense
what's your name again i'm brad
we didn't know pleasantries no but we
dispensed with all pleasantries
just i have a word from god for you now
by the way you should know
these moments are usually either very
awesome
or very terrible uh just for you know
i'm not don't
let the moral the story be always
believe everything
that someone when someone says you know
i've heard from god that's always from
god
no you need to discern it you know so
i've had some not so good experiences
with this
um but this was a good experience should
i have a word from god for you
uh she said one day you will lead
many churches
and then she turned around and walked
out the door
i had never seen her before i've never
seen her since
i haven't i don't even know her name i
have no idea maybe she was an angel
that's i don't know that's like that
that's my it's probably my childhood
like oh um it was i mean it was
completely fascinating now um
it's been a long road for me some of you
know my story rock you wrote it wasn't
like
i went to bible college and then i
became a pastor and it's been onward and
upward for me you know it's a little
bumpy journey
um and yet here here i am here we are
and as i was reflecting on that that
story this week i kind of
just the thought came to me that's kind
of a question um
well let me frame it like this when she
said that
i think that kind of it was just i mean
she was speaking prophetically right and
she was
kind of speaking to my what she
perceived what she since god was saying
was a certain destiny or call
in my life right and
that and it was for me i received it
kind of as a little bit of a promise
like hey god's doing something in your
life
and so the question that came to me this
week was
because of the rocky journey i've had
i've often gone back to that moment
and it's kind of sustained me in ways
and so the thought was would the table
be here today
if she had not said
that giving me that word that was a
question
now i don't know maybe maybe not
and it's such a powerful picture of the
fact that even these little moments
we just never know do we we never know
just a little act of love a little act
of kindness
might just set someone on a totally new
trajectory
i mean it's it's remarkable and
i mean it's the same idea right we're
we're all in the same boat
we are deeply and profoundly
connected to one another in ways we
don't even understand and we're having
an
impact on the people around us at levels
we we can't fathom and um
[Music]
and and i think um
well let me let me kind of try to sum
this up a little bit more and because i
i could kind of i wonder if someone's
kind of thinking like okay so yes we're
connected but like
how and like and what does that matter
exactly or what should i do different or
you know
a little let me answer a little bit of
this so what question you know because
it can seem maybe a little bit banal
like we're all connected okay so i just
live my life and then
i guess hopefully it's good so what does
this actually mean for us let me let me
phrase it um
like this because we are more connected
than we realize
um our words our actions our emotions
our feelings
are are much more impactful much more
contagious
than we realize that's that's that's the
inside that's what i'm driving at
um that's why i think i think this
really
really matters um so in that it's sort
of
terrifying and beautiful right
because on the one hand because i think
we tend to think of ourselves as we are
separate selves you know i'm just living
my life over here
hey i don't have an emperor who am i i
mean does anyone ever kind of feel like
that like i don't think i'm having any
impact in the world
i don't i think i'm mostly invisible i
don't and and i think that's where we're
underestimating ourselves
because we're looking for like big
things grand things
huge gestures you know we want to be i
don't know what is it that kids these
days influencers or you know we don't
have
million followers that person they're
making an impact
who am i who am i and yet if you think
of a life
my goodness the just sheer number of
people
you interact with i mean even today you
just like think through your day
i mean if you went out at all or heck i
mean you're here right now
so you just just had these little little
touches with like
these various people who are watching
you tuning in
well i think we're it's it's a pat it's
it's we're just
we're more powerful than we realize
we're having more of an impact than we
realize
so this is there's good news and bad
news here um bad news
is what you think is just yours isn't
and it actually is impacting the people
around you
obviously your family but even rippling
through your family
out forever right like it's
through into the interactions co-workers
family and it's kind of through them and
then through them out to everyone which
means
um for example your despair
that you think is just yours is actually
contagious
your hate that hatred that just that
venom you have for that person that
group it be whatever
and you think well i just keep that
under wraps you know nope
nope you don't you don't it's contagious
um you're hurt that those unhealed
wounds
contagious it's contagious it's it's
it's spreading
um your anger
contagious violence it's contagious
um your fear very contagious
very contagious so that's the bad news
what's the good news your love is
contagious
your peace again we are looking for big
gestures we're thinking i gotta do
something amazing
i don't know who you are who you if you
can just experience the peace of god
and carry that with you through the day
that is
profound and hugely impactful
on every person you interact with your
faith
contagious your hope contagious
is this making sense yeah um
coming back to the text i'm thinking of
um this moment when they
when the disciples are freaking out
verse 24 suddenly a furious storm came
up on the lake
so that the waves swept over the boat
that is this is scary
uh jesus was sleeping the disciples went
and woke him up saying lord save us
we're going to drown
do they sound calm nope nope
they are afraid and guess what that fear
contagious um you've never been around
someone who's afraid it's like
oh gosh should i be afraid too i don't
know if this is part of our kind of
evolutionary history i'm not sure we
just tune into fear and we're like oh
alert alert alert and
i and i kind of imagine the disciples it
was probably they were all a little bit
nervous and then one of them freaked out
that's i'm kind of speculating there
it's not in the bible but that's sort of
my guess one of
everyone was kind of nervous and then
one panicked and then before you know it
they're like
they're all just panicking uh
and why is this because we are
relationally emotionally
and even spiritually connected to one
another this is who human beings are
and so because of that we're just work
contagious
um for good and for ill
in fact we even have little folksy
sayings about this in the culture
this one came to me if y'all ever heard
if mama ain't happy
ain't nobody happy y'all heard this one
maybe did your mama say this to you
my mom did i don't know if she was
guilty of me i'm not sure what she's
doing
um if momma ain't happy ain't nobody
happy
uh and now what is this oh very exciting
yes for those online the children are
yelling
um when i was i was thinking about like
why is this saying i mean it's sort of
folksy and you know cutesy like
but it's actually it's kind of profound
cause what's it saying it's basically
naming
look often when mom's not happy well
then who else isn't happy
dad's not happy right and then once dad
gets unhappy well now he's lashing out
the children
and so now they're unhappy and then
before you know it
little cindy's like kicking the dog
and now the dogs like everyone the dog
has to go on antidepressants
because because mama wasn't happy
right and this is kind of human
community is it just
i mean this is basically saying we're
all in the same boat and it just we
we spread it just spreads i was thinking
even um of jobs are like this places of
work
i was talking with um she's not here
tonight but a friend who attends the
table
and she was saying that she got a new
boss
and the boss they're coming from a
different industry and they just don't
quite know what they're doing and
so um they are extremely anxious
and stressed out and it's already a
pretty high pressure job
but now this boss is anxious and
stressed out
and now the entire department what has
happened
everyone is what anxious and stressed
out this is also about leadership if you
can't totally tell this message is also
about leadership
because it's true that we all impact
each other like a peer level
but boy if you are leading anything from
you know a family
to uh anything of work you have
influence in any way
just know your whole vibe
your whole your your emotions who you
are in the soul
it is spreading like wildfire you may
not realize it and you're like man those
people they have such bad attitudes you
know i wonder why it is i
might look at the leader
and of course these are you know these
are small examples family you know
job but what's crazy is how this starts
to play out
in whole communities um
states nations
take on these vibes it's like it we're
all
we're all contagious and uh it
spreads now um you might be thinking
like oh gosh this is real depressing
because
uh i think human beings are a mess and
will probably never be fixed so
i guess all hope is lost um let's keep
reading our text
verse 25 the disciples went and woke him
saying lord save us we're going to drown
he replied you're right we are no
that's not what he said what did he say
you have a little faith
why are you so afraid do you get the
sense he's freaking out
i mean is there just in there just a
calm
you have little faith i mean i imagine
he's almost smiling
i mean they're in the middle of this
catastrophe of a storm on a boat
dangerous just you have a little faith
why are you so afraid
and then he got up and rebuked the winds
in the waves
just quiet and
it was completely calm this is i think
one of the most remarkable aspects of
who
jesus was that he was relationally
and emotionally he was connected to
people he was not telling this story of
disconnection
i'm over here and you all can just be in
your mess you know he wasn't he wasn't
like that he was
very relationally emotionally connected
and yet
he was immune
are you tracking he's and now what i
mean immune i'm thinking he's immune
to there in this case fear immune
to people's drama there's a lot of drama
in the world isn't there
you have a lot of drama i have a lot of
drama in my life
immune to the drama immune to the fear
um
immune to the anger
and he's i kind of imagine him as i have
an elm tree out in my front yard
that's like i don't know how old it must
be 80 100 years it's just
huge elm tree and have you ever seen a
really big tree in a storm
with those texas winds like it feels it
right the leaves are kind of swaying
but have you ever looked at the trunk of
a tree of a big tree in a storm
what's happening to the trunk very
pretty much
nothing it's just kind of
it's there and and i suspected we could
see underground the roots probably
aren't
swaying around in the wind either right
i think this is a picture of jesus who i
think was
deeply connected to the one he called
father
and i think it's a picture of who we are
called to be
um so jesus was immune
uh and yet jesus was also contagious
what do i mean he was contagi his love
his peace
his joy was deeply and profoundly
contagious if you're taking notes you
can write this down
people catch who i am on the inside
people catch it then you have to try it
just happens
people catch who we are on the inside i
think this is why jesus said
they'll know um you are my disciples
if you love one another that's not super
flashy
but effective people just see it they
just tune
into it um i'll close with this story i
think uh a great little pop cultural
example of this
for those with blessed enough to have
apple tv
um is the show ted lasso if any of you
have seen ted lasso is it's
really fantastic um you can watch you
know like little clips and stuff on
youtube
it's a great it's great so i won't you
know go into i won't give you an
hour-long synopsis but a very short
version is that
uh old ted so basically this is a good
thing we got a good picture of him
uh he uh so
basically he was brought over he was an
american football coach
and not like i mean he wasn't in the nfl
he was this is all fictional just to be
clear
um you know he's like kind of tier two
college coach
football and he's brought over to
coach a european um
basically men's professional soccer team
um and he of course i mean he
he knows nothing now he was the whole
kind of back story is that he was
basically brought here to
fail the owner for various reasons wants
the thing to fail
and so she's like i'll hire someone who
doesn't know what he's doing
and so she hires dead so he comes and
he's coaching and he's so
the thing is supposed to tank and i mean
i won't give the whole thing away this
is you figure all this out within the
first episode
but basically um it doesn't it it
doesn't tank
instead actually the team starts coming
together
he starts mentoring people like he
doesn't know anything about soccer
but what does he know he knows people
and he starts speaking in their life he
starts believing in them
he starts encouraging them and before
you know it
suddenly the team is coming together and
by the way the whole time he's hugely
criticized there are scenes
where you have tens of thousands of fans
chanting i won't say what they're
chanting well to say it's not
encouraging words towards
him uh and what does he do
or how much does he care not at all
doesn't care just like well i'm just
being me
he's immune and at the same time
he's completely contagious
so i guess what i'm driving at is we
tend to live life like we
are kind of separate selves
living separate lives when the truth i
think king's right i think the bible's
right we are caught up
in an inescapable network of mutuality
we're tied in a single garment of
destiny we're all in the same boat so
the question is
how immune are we
how contagious are we that's what i'd
like you to be reflecting on this week
all right let me pray for you lord jesus
i
i just lift up this community and
god i ask
that who we are on the inside god would
be transformed
that we would be like those trees deeply
rooted
and grounded in your love
just like your son jesus
who knew that he knew that he knew that
that you loved him
god would you do that deep work that
healing work in our hearts
thank god where we've been reactionary
and afraid
and blaming god would you bring
deep healing to us
and may our love may our peace may our
joy be contagious
god do your good work in christ's name i
pray
amen
[Music]
to everybody
through every heartbreak
through every circumstance
i believe you are my fortress
you are my portion
you are my hiding place
i believe you are
the way
and the truth
the lies
i believe you are
the way
the truth
in the life
i believe
[Music]
through every blessing
through every cross
[Music]
and you are the one i love
the way
the
[Music]
the truth
i believe
the way
the truth
[Music]
let's sing it's a new horizon
and it's a new horizon
and i'm set on you
you meet me here today with mercy
pet on you and all my fears and doubts
they can all come too because they
can't stay long when i'm here with you
it's a new horizon
and i'm set on you
and you meet me here today with mercies
that are new
all my fears and doubts
they can all come to you because they
can't stay
long when i believe you are
the way
[Music]
we believe you are
oh thank you worship team um so it's
really interesting because i
um just reflecting on this week um
impressed talking about
connections and things like that there
are times where
i'm tired um i
it's hard to sometimes just want to be
with other people it's time it's hard to
sometimes
try to pour into some something else or
someone else
um and there's just times where it's you
just don't know
where else you can give um and then you
actually show up
to this because there's either
a song that's sung a word that is spoken
a prayer that is
said there's some their connection
you've had with somebody that's in the
room
and it makes it all worth it to be able
to
walk out of here with some level of hope
and so i hope
that if you are ever in a space like
that
that you don't forget that there's a
reason why
we all come together and i say that to
lead into this next announcement
so we're about to go into where
we're going to get together everyone's
invited to um
hat creek um hat creek uh burger
that's here in taxi so
we would love for you to be able to come
to connect
to be able to reach out um for with
every with each other for
ever in the room and everything like
that and then
just hopefully maybe you walk out of
that conversation with some level of
hope
um to kind of help guests get out of
here a little faster there are just
several little things that need to get
done uh daryl wait
wait for a second there's daryl if you
wouldn't mind if you could
just help out just a little bit there's
banners and just signs and things like
that that just need to be taken down
it's just little logistic things that
just kind of help us kind of get out of
here real quick really quickly
so with that i want to dismiss this
prayer
lord thank you so much thank you for
all the people there in this room thank
you for the folks who are watching
online
thank you for just the ability to get
together and to connect with you
i pray that you just be with us this
week with all the different things that
we
have going on i pray that you fill us
with hope and a sense of purpose
in christ i pray amen